こんにちははじめ社長です今日は13時間でてました
13時間モデルうん13時間も見るとさすがにちょっとろうとしますね
泡がされたすごく安いと思ってるってよくてはちょっとボーっとしますけどちょっと
やってみたいかということでやります2尺シューターそして今対し
コツなベイブレードでございます目指しちょっとやってみたんですけど最近米命令の
アニメが始まりまして
またね暑くなってきてます趣味としてちょっとベイベー盗んで始めてみようかと本当に
思ってましてアニメの主人公が使っているこちらのベイブレード
ビクトリ針ティと言います web 過去が何をしようかと言いますとこの最新の
ベイブレードトミカ車かやってた普通のベイブレードがありますこれはカルっていうか
な
これとか知ってますかどの軍備1人2貫宿六ドライがオファー
んですまずで懐かしいグル防滴でこちらの初代ベイベーと正木からたっかしてもらい
ました
昔の初代のベイブレードでございますこの子のベイブルーの本で販売されたらすぐ
売り切れに出るのが難しかったんですけど
フラッシュリューポルドだ昔ベビーベッドですねぼくなイメージだとめちゃくちゃ強い
んですよ
倉科パルが強いんですよね西感じですね昔のベイブルーだ強かったそこで僕は思った
やめれーと母その1 d バルキリーこいつとこの初代のベイブレード戦わせたら
どっちが強いか
やの純粋な疑問ですよ今の技術が進歩してたら骨の発育を死んだしてひょっとしたら昔
のは強いされがと思う
drag it はめちゃくちゃ強い理由をという意味で今回は昔のベイブレード
今のベイブレードどっちが強いかちょっと検証してみようと思いますそれでね今の
ネバー空をつ良かったらめっちゃやる気が出るこれでて昔のベルディアドラが強かっ
たら
って上で早速育ててみましょう1回戦の相手はなんでなんとも言えないところまで倒す
かそいつでしょ
プラセール defense タイプですねここでならばはやくあっており1人でどう
やって戦うんが上がってまで見た一人で戦うんだろう
て人にやりましょうぜひ1回1000円取らせる大べき取りパリティリバーっと述べ
ビールは不怕で可能性あるからかなりハンディを持ってるわけよどこ中でどう違うん
ですかね
321号
すごいからつい21号
ていません
さあとしてよ
me
トップもいらっしゃ第1回姉御プリヴァルキリーのかつでございます
はぁ
pou dou dou
ドラ笑顔いない
あれ
ドライガーリングアウトの引き鳥ばできれば
登ってます
びっくりバレ斬りのこっち
on air 3やってるやってるやってる言ってるぞ
アクション
ぐるぐる回っているのがドライガーです
あれ嫌な予感がして来たーー
少佐ドライがあるんですねこれは仕方ないや攻撃タイプで接触できなかったら勝てない
からこれ相性的な問題かなと思います次
ドラン剤効果とランダー v 都度ランダーバランスタイプなのでなかなか猫
つかみどころのない戦い方をします号
ていました
さあさんさあどうなるか
me
あっはい今ちょっとちょっとちょっとちょっとちょっと回転した気がします
匹鳥バレ斬り担い最後はこちらドラグーンべき取りつつ人口木ノ宮タカオベイブです左
回転のドラゴンファインダーでありますから号
ええええええ
or これはこれはこれ
これは分からんぞ
これは何ぞ
図ったパッパ
いやぁああああああ
あーでも jk だけど妻へどうぞ車
4する書肆アクセスいいえ
いやー苦しいかんっ
ok ああ
ok
oko 僑居アーマーだダメだなまずままづかず一定タイプだからです
シャア
うわぁ歳
弱点ドライガーだ
需給現在2枚なうわぁ